per il momento di festa e oggi noto
lengies line non scegliere la busta
sorpresa sbaglia una abbiamo qua paribus
sorpresa a capire sorprese dentro linee
di un colore diverso e come funziona ma
ci sono sorpreso per le sorprese brutto
esatto una volta andremo a pescare un
abusato fredda e qualsiasi cosa c'è
dentro dovremo metterla nel nostro slime
con la nota perché non busta verde stato
vicino a nablus blu ancora non dobbiamo
scegliere dobbiamo prima vedere chi
inizia quando lasciate un bel vi piace
se volete vedere altri challenge slime
consigliati seppure nei commenti che
altre charlie's line volete che facciamo
quello che ci piace di più vi metteremo
un cuoricino e andremo realizzarla nel
canale 9 de liso le cose flight
challenge non scegliere lo chef
sbagliato e slime colori challenge
andate a vederli dopo questo video in
piedi questo video ci sarà la parola
segreta del gioco una sigaretta che di
dovesse cercare di sé riusciti a
trovarla la mente scriverla nei commenti
senza dire che la parola segreta del
giorno siete pronti come sempre prendete
sposati nel pop corn tè freddo succo di
frutta anguria parete
mettetevi comodi e cominciamo subito una
mischia
ma non per guardare dentro però io mi
hanno stato tutto questo verbo lontano
due mezzi si sono lasciati perché no
scusa e allora vediamo chi li carta
forbice sasso carta forbice sasso carta
forbice sasso ha mentito non devono
stare dentro che come lo stesso deciso
dal colore meglio 3 con il colore del
mio team colore blu delle grazie aspetta
prima di aprirla devo scegliere io la
mia busta sorpresa e poi lo apriremo
assieme vediamo che se posso solo
provare a guardare allora io l'ho
scenico occhi si mischiano
speriamo che vi porto il fatto che il
fatto di sanità occhi chiusi neanche vi
porti sfortuna
certo certo di carta da una spesa non
mischiamo bene farlo scelga questa la
farò biocchi giusti la prossima volta la
sega
si rischierebbe la violetta io piloto la
scelta verso l'area bene sapere che
avrei messo la mano qualche sono
intelligenti positivo tra gli stati
uniti tramite tramite le mie orecchie
[Musica]
diciamo che non mi fiderò più di te
sceglierò io adoro le sorprese quindi
sono proprio curiosa ok prima aprì la
sua grazie e devo far vedere tutte
baggianate certo cominciato con di
minare concertativi e poi abbiati su
altre cose
poi abbiamo che li l'inter dorati
fortuna e poi e infine con la glitter
d'oro come te che va ad occhi chiusi da
quella verde da fare per offriamo i
bambini massimo perché diversa è scaduta
brutta verità venga spesso diamo peso di
questo spettacolo altro ha spiegato
notturno pure marrone dall'altra mai
completate un pauroso marones ma anche
il grigio e stiamo apposta e qualche
volta verrone grigio e mine con battisti
lui ha guardato dentro una busta normale
fatto sapere che c'era anche il grigio
tre colori bruttissimi il verde parlare
del grigio da perline utilizziamo che
odiavo di più maledetta botta presa
[Musica]
fortuna ma è anche difficile recuperare
come faccia a recuperare perché non
abbiamo mai visto cosa che colore fa
verde più marrone è più grigio sarà mai
fatto andiamo a mettere i nostri
ingredienti in ordine il bottiglione di
queste frasi verde questo scoperto da un
lato è vecchio col ripete ma fa molto
verde pisello canto ma questo avverte
passato di piselli e bruttissimo ma è
poi abbiamo l'olio abbronzante come se
non bastasse lo sapete benissimo che è
bruttissimo affronterà lo slime
diventerà piano piano diventerà sempre
più marroncino perché non ore è marrone
rossastro è orribile
e poi cosa se non bastasse veramente io
ho avuto la sfiga più totalità dal primo
turno il grigio
voglio proprio vedere adesso brucia
parlato che splendido colore diventa
perché questa giornata giusta che ha
portato proprio la canzone ha fatto
sapere che cos'è questa cosa è allora
sta prevalendo il grigio però forse è un
po metallizzato quindi in borse nella
prossima busta mi capita un colore
carico series con può salvarlo per ora è
un grigio parlato brutto io da uomo
questo slime c'è fango invece sei stato
fortunatissimo
anch'io voglio andare in ordine quindi
procedendo subito con facciamo noi siamo
forse tutti e due sono mischiati no
grazie stiamo per cento euro si può mica
poi abbiamo a mettere questi argentati
però sporcato un po dappertutto tra
molla sera sembra sera per ai mettiamo
che proprio vedere come diventa lo slime
senapi lo bianco non è molto colorato
però meno tuo invece il 13 mo gol che ha
già studi non è finita qua perché cambia
capitarti una volta sbagliata poiché il
secondo round la nostra bus troviamo di
sogni prima carta fuori di sasso carta
pure ci passò a campanari giugno dai
quali temi ed a guardare il 7 posto dato
in sé porta una donna allora prima ho
scelto blu come il colore del mio team
adesso scelfo oro come blog live a non
guardare guardo mia vita
[Musica]
mamma mia che scenderà ad occhi chiusi
no che cosa dico io perché però lo so
che tu guardi entro la cosa mi metti
davanti dice fai ambarabà ciccì coccò no
non mi fido perché lo fai tu perché
certo
ma voglio maria ad ora io scelgo quella
del mio team rotta viola mi porti
fortuna perché pescato prima su vediamo
allora abbiamo castighi staff uschia
questo bellissimo con la foschia starà
benissimo fucsia
ma quali non potevano mettere nella mia
busta di apple ha detto io poi fragola
[Applauso]
che volete voi che credete brutta altra
non è possibile che sei stato fortunato
in pescata tour pescato tutte buone
intorno perché io no troppo fortunato
dottor paolo
[Musica]
il 56 com'era quando cominci con la
benedizione del beato devi continuare
shampoo aperte
bruttino è brutto anzi la fortuna non so
se ve lo ricordate nella challenge non
salire uno shampoo sbagliato che cosa
c'è alcuno nient'altro finito solo shell
e raffinata o c'è qualcosa che qui c'è
qualcos'altro
complice la lega lo sai di un verbo
stranissimo ora gareggia con verde però
splendida e alla fine riuscirà un bello
slancio migliori un pò guardà che brutto
che era questo
questo colore grigio canino sporchi esce
meglio aprire 10 meglio del mio credo
perché il ceroso donato roscomos uscirà
il mio retto bene alla prossima di
pescare quella giusta e non per la
sbagliata
vediamo fortuna mettiamo il nostro
shampoo verde che lo abbellirà ancora di
più se mai sarà almeno di fare un po di
colore su questo slam
e colore verde però no perché di questi
glitter lo stupendo messo tanti amici
del po di colore e ne diventa tutto
verte mi sa se il fango no e verde
grigio e bella eliminazione
lo sto migliorando parecchio a me sembra
ancora aver decreto è più frutto di
prima è un po un po bruttino però dai
almeno bertolo popolo sta correggendo fa
tra l'altro si sono polvere di great
cangiante all
ma avevamo fatto niente per migliorare
una gara che ha mangiato nulla
un po come diventa tra l'altro quella
line con la nuova che ho comprato questi
cliché che bei titoli reali e poi questa
nuova colla è detto si vuole poi regioni
nel colore sembra super super grossi
perfetto ma mi piace tanto questa colla
già
vediamo vediamo terra marrone che guarda
un bellissimo rose gold ma sono troppo
contento quando sono uscito bene non è
giusto io sono contento perché ho fatto
lo slide bellissimo sembra davvero una
fra torino e ci piace bello bello bello
solo dopo il pozzetto finora come no
ultimo turno ovviamente poi dovrò
scegliere solo una persona e era un prog
che questa volta mettero pescherò la
busta giusta così vitale fra quella
sbagliata che devo dare a rovinare tutto
è bene che mi vengono tutte e due giuste
oppure tutto e sbagliate che ne sai tu
non petto ma vedi cosa pensi cassaforte
successo che ha precisato
no io anche per ora l'idea rimane
scegliere lavoro ci vogliamo amore
scelgo quindi è deciso di andare allora
argento argento toia bene al centro con
l'inter e quindi lo presi io allora
scelto io il rosso da che è l'unico vi è
rimasto allora mettere io aspetterò la
lega che detto o povera da riportare un
ingrediente vuole per questa volta
bellissimo
[Musica]
vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro qua dentro
la la genialità attrività 6
qualcos'altro carlino di internet è
ancora terminato uno scende la busta a
busta argento sai che è robusta certo
c'è qualcosa o per associazione uno
pensa all'edizione la pletora di color
oro argento di color nero catania
possibile che sono state così spiegato
in questa zona non magari non calcio
fosse squagliata magari no dai vediamo
si beh non c'è altro quindi possiamo
chiudere qui la gialla di vedere
[Risate]
così come diventerà il tuo rosa così
bene non è un peccato che una bellissima
con quella folla vedere noi
io voto vitale solo perché questa
melodia testo perde in tutta avanti
adesso a berlino è stato anche fortunato
guarda che è trattato spiega tv si
ascolta visto che sei stato assomiglia
tissima ti propongo un cambio io prendo
i brillantini neri che col mio rosa
stanno bene e ti do in cambio quello
verde lo sia ascoltami ascoltami visto
che il tuo slimer verde con questo
colorante verde almeno diventa verde non
diventa nero visto che poi deve
aggiungere il nero dove invece dei
brillantini il mio non diventa marrone e
verde tanto non diventa perdere non ne
roma mi dispiace perché io preferisco
che si rovini joseline più che si
migliori il mio non vedo l'ora di
vederlo tutto marrone come no
lo spagnolo bene mettiamo il mio
amatissimo mero e sapete che ne passano
due gocce trasforma tutto quindi
l'ampera o grigio o il ritornato color
camion che vanno dai magari potrebbe
sembrare un galaxy poi di questo colore
mettiamo il glitter neri che non so
nemmeno se si legheranno io avevo
proposto prendeva il mio verde almeno ci
veniva così così nero un pugno a me
interessa io voglio che il tuo diventi
parole perché voglio proprio vedere come
diventa e così abbiamo due brutti ma non
c'è un vincitore
ok allora andando in ordine io comincio
con la colla color argento e sei stata
comunque fortunata fresca richiesta che
bella
e già mi rovino erompe attentati ma
capiterà è bellissima ma io lo volevo
color fragola
mi dispiace per te ma sta scoppiando e
poi mettiamo quello ciolino di santa
catarina
non penso che perfida crediamo che la
marrone ma prole
parole marrone
ma rumore anche il tutto è rovinato
anche se rimane comunque carino perché
in tanti glitter diventare più colorati
e il pistacchio come pistacchio di
lottato bene e nel male con il
pistacchio sta in pista è arrivato il
momento di affinare i nostri slime così
potrete votare chi vinse siete pronti
3 dove ora il quale il mio slime alla
fine pensavo in molto peggio dai
nonostante sia stata super sfortunata
con le buste sorpresa è uscito una
specie di grigio scuro ma per fortuna ci
sono un bel po di glitter così sembra
una sorta di galaxy
ora vi faccio sentire un po di studi
[Musica]
quindi questo il mio slime meno lunghi
con glitter cannes glitter verdi vediamo
ora quelle di vitale se nei tratti a
milano roseline questo fornaca
fantastico line pistacchio è anche bello
pistacchio quelli pezzettini di afragola
a me sembra più molto di strada è vero
che stupendo certo il colore lascia un
po a desiderare per corpo di anita che
ha voluto che non ho voluto fare lo
scambio certo colpa mia vero perché un
bel po king broker o bollicina poker non
tanto però rimane molto molto elastico
almeno indizi ma è stato bravo nono
attivarono troppo queste mosse di tron
ha pensato del colore peccato perché con
il corrosa se non so se solo non fosse
uscito quel verde guarda vediamo un po
chi vince
c'è bisogno e votate nel sondaggio e
fateci sapere che altre zone blu volete
vedere nei commenti e ora vi lasciamo a
quattro cantoni e su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri media cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao